you're my only daughter
if i say that you should be married then
married you should be uh
where is the lady catherine i've come
here to propose marriage a man has come
and asked for me by name you cannot mean
our lady catherine she's a vile creature
some say she has a third ear she does
have you seen this third year i've seen
it where back of her neck
is it functional
i'm not interested in meeting him not
any man with his intentions
would i choose to die rather than be
forced to marry i do not think either
option appealing or fair
i cheer for you birdie i fear for you
i am thankful
very cunning most girls are they are not
giving you credit for it i do think
she's come down with something she's got
a little little um little little little
bit of i think there's a little bit of
pox going around the village parks
parks oh no i mean it's not the village
oh you
it's only a small
little box
you'd like to go anywhere your father
isn't
there horribly duplicitous
you must learn how to harness them you
don't get to decide who we are where we
go or how much we cost like we just
things we got things with people and we
can think and we can hear we can feel
but we are here
i wish i could help every girl in the
world
knowing your own story will be your
salvation
but for now
i am enough
[Music]
you